alright hello everyone again we're going
to talk about Ultron again and that fun
but does mean you don't know or maybe
you're new to my channel the movies
really cool and fun to talk about I'll
do a spoiler video after my spoiler free
review which is funny because I loved
whiplash didn't do one for that it's
kind of contained two summer movies for
the most part made [ __ ] I'm gonna do one
for Star Wars you know I'm gonna do one
for that it comes out in December all
right you get the jet so that's a
spoiler warning we're gonna talk about
some spoilers and Avengers age of Ultron
so if you don't want that leave now or
watch my spoiler free review you can do
that we're gonna fast-forward to the
part where Ultron gets created because
that's really from that is what matters
right gets created like Loki's staff
looks like it's thinking so it's oh my
god that's the key to make an artificial
intelligence right there I was like ah
[ __ ] it's gonna be like one of those
things for Ultron's mind his
consciousness is the staff that freaked
me out but it wasn't it wasn't like that
it's actually just one of those things
where completes the algorithm so Ultron
gets created he comes out is busted up
body and he's like me strange which is
great because a couple of the drones he
sets him to attack the Avengers but he
gets a wipe down like two seconds just
like what did but initially you see how
hard this guy's gonna be to kill because
he escapes on the internet just uploads
to another body and that happens a
couple times an age of Ultron just wipe
him out doesn't matter now he's in
another body reminded me of Battlestar
Galactica with the resurrection
technology I was like that is scary when
you're fighting something that you can
kill but not kill that's just scary to
me but he first becomes self-aware he's
downloading data data data at this crazy
rates kind of like The Fifth Element Lee
loses just reading through [ __ ] she's
like ugh it's the war and she's just
like you know I don't think Humanity is
worth saving so it's a fast thing that
happens but you get it you kind of feel
like he has simulated enough information
to last a lifetime the rush part for me
is I wish he had gone through a couple
bodies before he got to what we know is
Ultron prime couldn't you go from like
the busted up one to another one that's
not quite as good to another one that's
not quite as good well in any case we
have Ultron and now he's just
frightening and I said in my review
there was a point in the movie where I
was like you know this movie is reaching
deeper levels and I was thinking about
it it's actually a couple of events that
all go back to back first of all it's
when Scarlet Witch just hypnotizes
everybody after they go meet Andy Serkis
by them I mean Ultron and his crew shake
him down for his vibranium it's kind of
a mixed bag right there because when
Scarlet Witch hypnotizes The Avengers
and goes into their brains and they
start having hallucinations and visions
half of it setting up for their arch you
know it's like Thor's seeing things for
Ragnarok I really liked
black widows I was like oh my gosh we
see more with black widow that's awesome
that was enough for me to go I think
we're getting somewhere now set up a
side I think we're actually focusing up
and I love the fact that Tony Stark sees
his crew dead because I mean if you
think about the Avengers he's the only
one that went up into that portal and
saw the aliens before he blew him up he
knows what's coming no one else really
does this is a weight that he is
carrying so I can see why he's like you
know I don't care we're creating Ultron
we're gonna put a net of armor on the
world right totally gonna work out so I
did like that I like the layers of Tony
Stark's if they're using in this movie
too but again everyone was getting
hypnotizes like son of a [ __ ] Hawkeye
is gonna get hypnotized again nobody
takes an arrow and he's like ravaged his
electrocute Scarlet Witch is like I did
that thing before doesn't work for me I
was like nice and in this movie
generally speaking Hawkeye he is a very
important part of the movie like when
they hang out at mom pock hands farm
that actually ends up being Hawkeye and
his wife and the kids farm I was like oh
my god Hawkeye is not just an agent he's
a dude he's a father he's a husband I
love moments like that it should have
slowed the movie down and grinded down
to a halt and I'm like oh the phasing oh
god it's slowing down but it didn't it
engaged me even more like oh this is
what we're fighting for this is why we
need to stop Ultron it's pretty much
those events going back to back rows
like now this movie has me Ultron has a
great personality and a wicked sense of
humor I didn't really expect him to have
the sense of humor that I know James
Spader has and I guess when you're
created by Tony Stark you're going to
have that Ultron does have great legs I
have a couple of favorite lines from
Ultron one is when he gets the vibranium
vibranium is what Captain America
shields made out of he's like the most
versatile substance on the planet and
they used it to build a frisbee and the
other is that quote he says Andy Serkis
was like keep your friends rich and your
enemies rich and wait to see which is
which I might be paraphrasing but I
really love that quote
that is one tweetable quote right there
but another big thing in this movie is
Paul Bettany as vision ultimately again
kind of like how they created Ultron
they use Jarvis to create visions
consciousness but he's not actually
Jarvis and visions body was going to be
Ultron super body so I guess like Ultron
prime is an Ultron Prime this was going
to be Ultron prime but they took it now
he's crazy awesome vision who is one of
the coolest characters oh my god cuz not
only is he articulate and he's wise he's
a soft spoke
guy he is opposite into the coin of
Ultron he's a badass into completely
protective kind of ways but Ultron was
supposed to be I love this was the oh
[ __ ] I'm actually sure I actually said
out loud
oh [ __ ] when this happens they're all
like we don't know if we trust you man
you're one of Tony Stark's mad
experiments again you're another Ultron
how do we know you're not and he's like
I'm a protector I protect life Ultron
doesn't we need to stop Ultron I don't
want to destroy Ultron he's unique but
he threatens all life on Earth and so we
must and I know there's no way to get
you to trust me but until you do and he
grabs Thor's hammer just hands it to him
like it's a suitcase or something's like
we have work to do and it's like what
did he just do cuz they all have the
same look on their face they're all
thinking oh sure and you find out
Ultron's big evil plan is to take a big
huge town this section of earth raise it
into the sky and just slam it into the
earth like a meteor an astronomical
extinction event of godly proportions
Ultron's gonna do it those are some
pretty high stakes right thermally yeah
that we just wipe out mankind alright
let's stop him so when they're trying to
stop him is like we can't let all try
and get to that thing that's gonna drop
this section of earth is just going up
and they're like we need to either blow
this thing up or get everyone off and
like they're like let's blow it up it's
easy man didn't you watch Heroes you can
wipe out a city to save the earth let's
just do that right now and caps like
we're not leaving anyone on this rock
we're getting them all off I'm like
that's why you're Captain America man
so they're all trying to do that and
this is one of the scenes for us like oh
god there are a few scenes in this movie
that made me like one little concept of
Black Widow and Bruce Banner they kind
of have this romance thing going but you
know it's not gonna work out even at a
point Holt gets into the jet and he just
turns off the screen and he flies off
and it's like I guess he's gone now that
was one of them the other one a very
easy you know what it's gonna be it's
when Hawkeye has that kid and the just
machine guns just gonna lose it's gonna
wipe him out and he just turns and then
Quicksilver just snags him out of there
and then like Hawkeye and this kid are
in this other place and he looks up and
Quicksilver just has holes in him he
just drops to the ground he dies in his
car that which just rages I just it was
like meh no man the life family dynamic
hit and you're right there I'm really
glad Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
turned goodness movie you know you guys
are just being played by Ultron you know
smarter than that and they kind of
become Avengers I love that speech that
Hawkeye gives he's like we're fighting a
huge robot on a floating island and I'm
armed with a bow now none of this [ __ ]
makes sense if you step out that door
you are an Avenger you need to decide
what you need to do but I was honestly
hoping they would have to blow this
island up like you know what you got to
make the tough call sometimes sometimes
she don't get everyone out I'm still
waiting for the Avengers to run into a
moment like that but not today to get
everyone out they blow this thing up
everything drop today save the world and
everyone in the town which is a bit
squeaky clean for me but by the time
they do it you're like yeah I'm with you
we had to get everyone out of that town
I totally like flipped on my initial
mindset words like yeah people after
dies needs to happen with the Avengers
need to learn that lesson
there's like elbows I think at 15
minutes ago what the hell is that guy
now he doesn't know anything
I love the fact there's that one Ultron
drone left and visions in front of them
and it's Ultra is the last it's the last
Ultron body you wipe this thing out
Ultron's gone and he and vision are
talking I love the dialogue between the
two of them those two ends of the coin
or just talking back the end of the
conversation when vision gives his
wisdom and Ultron's like you are
incredibly naive ambition thanks for a
second ago well I was created yesterday
and you know that's the thing that would
just enrage Ultron and then Ultron gets
pissed and vision just wipes him out
with his forehead cannon and then in the
end of the movie it all wraps up they
depart they go their separate ways
Captain America and Black Widow stay on
to train the new Avengers and he shows
them his Falcon and war machine who
helped out with that whole the world's
gonna end thing with Ultron Scarlet
Witch and vision I was like well Captain
America was like all right let's whip
them into shape like they're green or
something which they are for the most
part but vision is their last vision
what he was he simply said I am that is
what God said to Moses in the Bible but
they're gonna whip vision into shape it
felt like visions gonna look out and be
like don't irritate me man you act like
you know what you're talking about you
don't I am and then the post-credits
scene you knew it was going to be in
there is just this golden gauntlet with
no stones in it and Thanos puts his hand
in there he's like fine I'll do it
myself my question is if one of the
Infinity stones is envisioned for head
in order for Thanos to complete it is he
going to rip it out of vision's heads
vision just or is he destined to die now
could you imagine he's going to get all
the stones in his gauntlet which means
that one's gonna leave visions head I
feel like visions just toast in the end
guys I love talking Spore
I like going into you know deeper realms
of the movie that I can't really do like
reviewing a movie she's really tricky
thing so you want to get your point
across you want to touch on points but
you don't want to have spoilers you
don't wanna spoil and move your people
haven't seen it and it's the point of
something like this and there's more
than enough to talk about an age of
Ultron point is I liked the movie and
then I loved the movie and I walked out
of this movie going yep I don't know how
else I could have executed this movie to
make it that good you would think the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is be getting
old at this point but it's really not
I'm still on board I still love them so
I already asked you if you've seen age
of Ultron my question now is what's your
favorite Ultron moment your favorite
line favorite thing that Ultron did in
this movie he did a lot you got to have
a favorite moment whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more